Now if you could do all of these just by writing with a pen,
you wouldn't be in a computer class.
So let's start modeling this.
And so we're going to do our concept inventory.
So what do we have? Well, these individual results here
come from random variables.
So a random variable is like the first child born,
which can be a boy or a girl.
The whole universe is called the sample space,
and then these individual sets of circles
are called events--like the event of having (2 boys),
or the event of having at least 1 boy.
And an event consists, then,
of a collection of sample points.
So a sample point is BG, GB or BB.
In terms of representation,
we're going to just represent sample points as strings.
So we'll have like the string, 'GG',
and we can represent events two ways:
as a collection of strings
or as a predicate--
a function, which is true of certain strings and not of others.
So here's what I did: I imported
itertools because we're going to need that.
I searched for--and found--a new class, called fractions,
within the fractions module,
and there's a function or a constructor, called fraction,
which produces an exact fraction.
And the reason I wanted that is because
when the answer is 1/3, I wanted to see that it was exactly 1/3.
I didn't want to see that it's .33333.
So all a fraction is is a numerator and a denominator,
paired together, and they know how to do arithmetic.
So here's my random variable.
I represent that as a collection of possibilities in here--
I just strung the possibilities together.
I could have said set of 'BG' or the list of 'B,G'
but I just put them together, as a string.
Then I said we can combine random variables
with a cartesian product--and I used itertools.product--
and then I just said: get all results,
which itertools.product produces tuples,
and I want to look at them as strings.
So now two_kids is the product of two children
and we're looking at their sex.
So if I evaluate that, I get this collection.
And one_boy is just the points in two_kids
that have at least one boy in the string.
So it would be this one, this one, and this one.
And then I can define two_boys as a predicate.
That's saying that's True
when the count of the number of boys is equal to (2).
That would be True here.
And finally, I can define my conditional probability.
That says what's the probability of (p), given (e),
where (e) is an event specified
as a list of sample points,
all equal, probable, and predicate;
is a predicate that returns True or False
of elements of that event,
and so the True elements are just the ones for which it is True,
and then I returned a fraction--
how many out of the event satisfy the predicate.
Then I can ask, what's the conditional probability
of two_boys, given one_boy--and the answer is 1/3.
So that's what we expected.